[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8
politique sur tv 78 merci de nous
rejoindre deux invités aujourd'hui bruno
myle yens le président du modem des
yvelines réélu à ce poste fin novembre
nous parlerons avec lui de sa formation
mais aussi et de sa place au sein de
l'hémicycle
bruno myle yens soutien de la république
en marche est aussi député de la 9e
circonscription avec isabelle
this-saint-jean conseillère régionale
d'île de france il sera question de la
refondation du ps et les membres de la
direction collective du parti
elle nous dira comment elle envisage
l'avenir et puis nous accueillerons
aussi sur ce plateau des lycéens de
montigny le bretonneux élève de
terminale es ils jugent l'action des
élus et nous parlons aujourd'hui de la
sélection à l'entrée de l'université
isabelle this-saint-jean bonjour je vous
remercie de nous avoir rejoints sur ce
plateau conseillère régionale d'île de
france je le disais membres de la
direction collective du parti socialiste
vous êtes universitaire également le ps
qui traverse une crise profonde
on va dire clairement les choses
aujourd'hui après une élection
présidentielle délicate depuis le
candidat benoît hamon a lancé son propre
mouvement alors qu' aujourd'hui pour
porter la voix de ce parti et puis
surtout quel message véhiculé
c'est aujourd'hui tout le travail qui
vous qui vous occupez est ce qu'on peut
dire aujourd'hui que le parti socialiste
a toujours néanmoins un avenir alors moi
je suis absolument convaincu 1 je suis
absolument convaincu que dans le paysage
politique extrêmement compliqué dans
lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui
avec une crise démocratique parce qu'il
faut jamais oublier que le premier parti
de france c'est d'abord l'abstention est
que beaucoup de nos concitoyens se
détournent de la représentation
démographe démocratique dans cette crise
politique de fragmentation de
recomposition eh bien je crois que oui
il ya tout à fait la place pour une
offre politique qui est celle que je
crois qu'il faut que nous portions
absolument préoccupé des problématiques
de justice sociale et d'inégalités et en
particulier de la situation des plus
fragiles d'entre nous qui est
profondément attaché à la démocratie qui
est profondément préoccupé des questions
environnementales et écologiques et
notamment climatiques mais pas seulement
et qui par ailleurs porte l'europe tout
en étant absolument lucide c'est
probablement l'une des racines des
difficultés dans le com nous sommes deux
du fait que bien sûr en tant que
socialiste on est les héritiers de
jaurès et blum mais que le 21e siècle
est un siècle qui se traduit par
l'irruption d'un certain nombre de
problématiques totalement nouvelle et
qui nécessite qu'on reprenne les choses
mais ces socialistes sur ces questions
là aujourd'hui au niveau national c'est
alors s'il s'est dit alors c'est
difficile pour plein de raisons - c'est
difficile parce qu'effectivement on
traverse une crise majeure les élections
nous ont laissé dans un état de
fragmentation de tensions internes
absolument mais qui ont marqué tout le
quinquennat
je pense qu'il faut vraiment faire
l'analyse lucide des responsabilités des
uns des autres sur cette situation
kiki qui font recontextualiser dans une
crise de la démocrate de la social
démocratie pour les origines sont celles
que je mentionnais tout à l'heure donc
il est difficilement audible en même
temps et donc moi j'ai eu la
responsabilité de ça on a décidé de
prendre un moment ensemble pour
travailler sur le fond avec les
militants ce que je dis ensemble aux
roms dollars c'est la somme qui se
tiennent sur dans toutes les fédérations
dans les sections alors de manière plus
ou moins active selon les lieux mais il
se passe beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
par ailleurs qu' à une série
d'entretiens à solférino avec un certain
nombre de chercheurs et d'intellectuels
que je pilote sur les grandes questions
qui font rupture donc il n'y a pas et
quant à la question de qui pour incarner
ne commençons pas parce à la personne
qui incarnera le parti socialiste elle
devra surtout être porteuse du projet
que collectivement et quand je dis
collectivement c'est l'ensemble des
militants c'est pas les chefs à plumes
qui sont là-haut ça n'a pas ça n'a pas
de sens aujourd'hui c'est l'ensemble des
forces militantes du parti socialiste
qui travaillent qui ensemble élabore une
offre politique et celui ou celle ou
ceux d'entre nous qui seront chargés de
conduire le parti le conduire à mme fort
de ceux de ce projet de rien et ça sera
bien fini après le congrès s'agit 8
avril c'est à dire que la réflexion
à mon avis elle doit continuer après
c'est pas un congrès de clarification
entre deux beaux airs ans
aujourd'hui on nous appelle sans parler
des des noms il ya même des noms qui
ressortent à 1 najat vallaud belkacem
stéphane le foll julien dray est ce que
tous ces gens là ont des points communs
de mes blessures c'est ça qui est
incroyable hein c'est que il ya une
cohérence en fait absolument
extraordinairement forte en fait à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste et ça
tombe bien qu'on nous a fait pendant
tout le quinquennat le coût des deux
gauches irréconciliables qui était en
fait je suis désolé de le dire mais
quand même des moyens d'occuper des
postes
voilà et d'avoir des stratégies
personnelles qui ont alors le il faut
faire l'analyse ce qui s'est passé et je
pense qu'il faut faire des autocritiques
partout mais on voit bien quand même
comment ça a été instrumentalisée de
tous les côtés et que ça s'est traduit
par des français qui nous ont regardés
absolument sidéré en se disant mais
qu'est ce qui se passe avec un bilan du
quinquennat que vers avec ce bilan n'est
qu'un cas alors je suis ses droits
d'inventaire c'est à dire que je
considère qu'il ya des choses positives
dans le bilan qui a eu des choses par
exemple un truc qu'on dit jamais cette
politique a été redistributive faut
quand même le dire un moment dans un
moment de montée des inégalités cette
politique a été redistributif à côté de
ça il ya des choses dont la capacité
d'écrire un récit politique d'expliquer
aux gens ce qu on fait le fait d'avoir
minoré la crise de la fin des années
2000 qui les sept pays dans une
situation quand même de très grande
gravité des problématiques comme la loi
travail la manière dont elle a été menée
et sans parler de la déchéance et je
rajouterais la question universitaire
dont j'imagine que vous allez par les
travailleurs
moi je suis extrêmement sévère à l'égard
du bilan sur sur les universités et sur
la recherche
voilà il ya un certain nombre de points
qui sont des points négatifs il ya des
points positifs il faut pas se dire que
nous n'avons pas agi nous collectivement
1 j
positivement je pense que dans les
points négatifs aussi le repli sur une
parti socialiste de plus en plus étriqué
gouvernance bon bah tout ça c'est des
choses qu'il faut dire directement qu'on
est en train de se dire entre nous la
situation de benoît hamon aujourd'hui
moi je faire pas moins de candidats à
l'élection présidentielle qui était
aussi député dans la 11e circonscription
des yvelines il a perdu son siège
on peut aussi aller un petit peu plus
loin parce qu'il est conseiller régional
il a fondé un nouveau
il a rejoint nouveau avec sandrine et
longue rampe qui était qui et qui était
la responsable du ps dans le département
des yvelines qui a été écarté depuis
alors on va faire quand même un mot sur
la fédération du ps donné dans les
yvelines
mais déjà sur benoît un mot en tant qu'
en tant que tel
par rapport à ça quand pointe une par
rapport à son programme par rapport à sa
position aujourd'hui penser qu'il a fait
du mal au ps non moi je me désole
vraiment je faisais de cette situation
alors je sais qu'on est dans une forme
d' irréversible mais je m'en désole
parce que en fait quand on regarde les
choses d'un peu loin quand on est quand
on essaye de voir les projets les
principes les valeurs je ne vois pas où
est la différence entre benoît hamon et
le parti socialiste je ne comprends pas
il se dit ils portent fortement
l'écologie il la porte est fortement
dans la campagne mais le parti
socialiste s'était dit social écologiste
depuis un moment
pendant le quinquennat c'est quand même
des questions alors bien sûr on pourrait
aller plus loin il faut aller plus loin
plus vite mais la question des accords
de paris c'est quand même pas rien la
loi de transition énergétique c'est
quand même pas rien si on prend un autre
sujet le revenu universel dont on a
beaucoup débattu pendant la campagne
qu'il a portés c'étaient les nos
concitoyens ne le savent pas mais
c'était inscrit dans ce qu'on appelle
les cahiers de la présidentielle
exercice fait par le parti socialiste
qui avait porté cette proposition donc
ou où est la différence
on est tous d'accord de se mettre à la
main et oui je pense qu'il a tort parce
que ça fragilise la famille que nous que
nous sommes la famille au sens noble du
terme
la famille que nous sommes porteurs
d'idées de principes de valeurs et d'un
projet sur lequel il faut qu'on
travaille ensemble
donc moi je me désole de cette de cet
épisode
je ne sais pas comment ça évoluera à
l'avenir je pense qu'il faut vraiment
voilà assez rapidement enfin en tous les
cas moi la mission que je me suis donné
c'est de faire en sorte qu'on ait un
parti socialiste qui soit pleinement en
phase avec les défis les enjeux et
porter quand même d'un
d'un espoir s'il faut pas seulement
pointé les défis on a des opportunités
on a des choses à dire et on a à
convaincre nos concitoyens que quand on
est élu c'est pas simplement pour
obtenir des pseudos privilège mais c'est
parce qu'on veut concrètement changer
leur vie au quotidien
les transports leur logement l'éducation
l'université pour les jeunes chantier on
arrive à la fin de cet entretien de cet
échange juste un mot concernant le parti
socialiste des yvelines
aujourd'hui le parti soucier des
yvelines qui est en période de
transition aussi puisque je le disais
sandrine grand bond n'est plus sa
responsable pour l'instant comment vous
jugez la situation il ya une
reconstruction complète à faire dans le
département des yvelines et je crois oui
oui je crois que ça va être enfin c'est
à l'aune de ce qui se passe dans le
parti socialiste donc on est dans un
épisode de refondation j'ai dit tout à
l'heure que c'est selon moi ça ne
s'arrêtait pas au congrès un que c'était
fallait se projeter plus loin de 100
et donc évidemment dans les yvelines
tout est à d'une certaine manière à
reconstruire puisque c'était une
fédération quitter ou la personnalité de
benoît hamon était quand même très très
très présente
il a décidé de nous quitter de nous
quitter pour monter son mouvement
personnel bon bah voilà donc on va il
faudra qu'on fasse vers aussi avec son
sac voilà avec tous comportent avec les
militants qui sont à nos côtés pour
avancer conforme de refonder ce de la
refondation qui se déroule en ce moment
et puis le congrès ce sera tôt début
avril au niveau national pour le parti
socialiste isabelle this-saint-jean
remercie restez avec nous encore
quelques instants le sujet d'après va
forcément vous intéresser bonsoir à tous
les deux vous êtes deux étudiants élèves
de terminale es au lycée emilie de
breteuil guillaume et emma et vous
intervenez aujourd'hui pour nous parler
de la sélection à l'université un sujet
qui va forcément vous vous intéressez en
tant qu'universitaire alors quel regard
portez-vous sur cette question alors on
est le 1er décembre les enfants ce matin
où la voix de découvrir la première case
du calendrier de l'avent les calendriers
de l'avent c'est un peu comme l'histoire
du père noël
c'est enfantin quand on grandit
l'histoire s'arrête et ce qui est sympa
avec le gouvernement c'est qu'on a
l'impression que justement l'histoire
continue on a depuis le mois de juin a
l'impression d'ouvrir tous les jours une
nouvelle case du calendrier de l'avent
et la dernière surprise en date c'est la
sélection à l'université contextualise
ont un peu notre réveil de ce matin en
découvrant la sélection du coup pour la
première fois depuis des années le
budget de l'enseignement supérieur a été
baissée par le gouvernement de macron de
330 millions d'euros l'augmentation du
nombre de naissances dans les années
2000 va faire que les effectifs dans les
universités va être croissant d'année en
année et
doute nous conte de moins de moins de
prétendants à l'université apb était un
système qui était défaillant et injustes
les dernières trois milices à sont quand
même restés sur le carreau sans santé
assurance habitation et ont du travail
et du coup un temps dans la tente d'une
une seconde phase d'admission il fallait
effectivement revoir ce système
donc la logique sera bien entendu
d'augmenter les moyens pour contre les
universités plus grande et aussi
permettra de bacheliers d'intégrer du
coup les filières auxquels ils sont
destinés
mais au contraire le budget prévisionnel
de 2010 est pour l'année 2010 8
prévoyait une baisse de 330 millions
d'euros sur l'actuel budget de
l'enseignement supérieur l'université ne
souffre pas d'un manque de sélection le
contrat des conséquences de la sélection
par l'échec organisées au sein des
premiers cycles dont sont victimes en
priorité les étudiants précaires et qui
sont issus pour la plupart des milieux
populaires
donc quelle est donc cette fameuse
surprise celle que nous prépare le
gouvernement
le gouvernement propose un plan
étudiants quelques mois avant la fin de
l'année scolaire
provoquant forcément l'incertitude des
lycéens et d'administration hissène et
universitaire donc il s'agit de parcours
sup
le nouvel app et b qui a été nommé par
conjointement avec le ministre de
l'éducation et de l'enseignement
supérieur madame vidal bon il n'a pas
encore fait ses preuves
donc nous pouvons pas juger de son
efficacité mais on peut toujours
s'interroger sur leurs choses déjà on
juge favorable la fin du tirage au sort
qui est profondément injuste
cette méthode ne permettez pas à tous
les étudiants d'accéder à l'université
aux filières qu'il souhaitait mais du
coup l'école de la république se doit
donner les mêmes chances à tous et la
mise en place d'une sélection qui trient
les bacheliers c'est aussi pas fou et
c'est ce droit à l'université à tous
ça nous satisfait également que ceux qui
auront les meilleurs dossiers seront
acceptés en priorité on pense
sérieusement que c'est une mauvaise
réponse au problème de démographie au
manque de moyens qui sont en cours
actuellement il ya une volonté des
jeunes de se former et on y répond pas
en renforçant ce système élitiste un
système très élitiste qui est notamment
fondée sur la participation au
financement des écoles privées les
tailles et participe à hauteur de 20%
donc c'est à dire que ceux qui sont déjà
le plus avantagé ce économiquement
seront également avantagé scolairement
donc ça renforce évidemment ce système
élitiste et qui ne permet pas de gommer
les inégalités de la société donc très
critique tous les deux sur cette réforme
qui se met en place des universités et à
ces regards vont porter sur ce que vous
entendez ah non monsieur moi j'ai je
pense que voilà c'est dans les points
noirs du dernier quinquennat il ya le
fait qu'on n'a pas été à la hauteur sur
l'université et sur la recherche
on aurait dû on décroche un par rapport
à tous les autres pays grands pays on
avait une force extraordinaire qui était
notre recherche et notre système
d'enseignement supérieur même s'il a
beaucoup de fragilité et on n'a pas
redonné les non nécessaires dans un
moment où vous l'avez dit tout à fait
justement on a un choc démographique
dont il faut se réjouir mais qui est
extrêmement fort il aurait fallu
construire à peu près deux universités
par an les chiffres c'est 100 et on ne
l'a pas fait on l'a fait à la fin du
quinquennat il ya eu un rattrapage et
c'est bien mais il ya eu une erreur
majeure qui a été le tirage au sort par
pour l'est pour la sélection ça c'était
incompréhensible ça se faisait déjà en
fait dans les universités
donc évidemment il ne fallait pas faire
ça il fallait mettre des moyens
considérables
l'échec en premier cycle c'est
absolument multifactorielle il fallait
jouer ce qui a été fait quand même 1 sur
les bourses sur le logement sur la vie
des campus mais il fallait amplifier cet
effort et là effectivement juste quand
j'ai su en un mot en un mot de
conclusion effectivement là nous avons
un principe de sélection dans un moment
où il faudrait amener plus de jeunes de
tous les milieux sociaux à
l'enseignement supérieur c'est
nécessaire pour eux et c'est nécessaire
pour nous tous c'est l'avenir
merci habitent ces chargeurs d'être
venus participer à cette phase à 7,8
politique un mot de conclusion peut-être
aussi si vous aviez un dernier mode
rapidement pourquoi est-ce qu'on aurait
préféré un chocolat ce matin on ouvre on
accuserait le calendrier de l'avent tout
simplement parce que on a put on était
plutôt sage tanné qu'on aurait voulu a
commandé au père noël en droit d'accès à
l'université pour tous parce que
l'université c'est un droit ne doit pas
devenir un privilège et qu'on voudrait
des moyens supplémentaires pour pouvoir
s'y épanouir et elles n'ont pas à avoir
des échecs comme ce qu'on a en ce moment
donc on espère que le gouvernement
entendra de bonnes résolutions pour
l'année 2018
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'être
venus aussi pour cette chronique autour
de la réforme des universités merci à
guillaume et marie-eve de terminale es
au lycée emilie de breteuil
merci à vous merci à tous les trois un
nouvel invité va nous rejoindre à
présent bruno myle yens c'est le
responsable du modem dans le département
des yvelines
il est également député des yvelines
bruno myennes bonjour vous en prie
installez vous voilà vous avez été réélu
à la présidence du modem dans le
département des yvelines fin novembre
réélu à 97 4% petite précision
vous étiez le seul candidat oui c'est un
suspense insoutenable joue là je vous
confirme ce sera le mandat de la
continuité
oui de la mi-août chantier il ya des
chantiers parce que notre situation un
tout petit peu changé par rapport à la
dernière fois vu que nous sommes une des
deux jambes de la majorité
présidentielle même s'il ya un petit peu
plus courte en terme nombre de députés
mais malgré tout on a notre place et
donc ça a forcément des incidences sur
les fédérations départementales avec un
axe peut être beaucoup plus politique
que que ce qui avait été fait
précédemment
on s'est beaucoup occupé de formation de
détection de les trouver des gens et
maintenant il faut effectivement qu'on
les forme politiquement dans la ligne de
nos valeurs on ne pour ne quittera pas
nos valeurs
est ce qu'il ya une priorité ce sont les
élections européennes aussi voir locales
aussi il ya les élections européennes
c'est important pour le modem parti baas
et européens c'est important pour le
modem ça l'est aussi pour le parti du
président emmanuel macron puisque vous
voyez bien que sur l'europe on est comme
parfaitement phase est en ligne avec la
république en marche et je salue
d'ailleurs l'initiative du président
ainsi que du gouvernement de passer à
des listes nationales
ça va nous permettre d'avoir un débat de
fond de ne pas régionaliser justement le
débat sur l'europe et d'aller au fond et
de pouvoir mesurer à quel point il est
important que tout le monde se mette
autour de la table dans l'europe au
moins sur la zone euro pour qu'on puisse
se reconstruire cette europe qui a été
une europe marchande jusqu'à maintenant
de libre marché de libre concurrence et
qu'on fasse enfin l'europe de la
fiscalité et l'europe sociale pour
parler du modem et du paysage politique
et pour être bien clair aujourd'hui le
modem arrive à exister au sein de la
république en marche
je ne prendrai qu'un seul exemple celui
d'hier soir nous étions dans ce qu'on
appelle vous savez les niches en fait
les groupes parlementaires en droit à
une journée par an pour faire des pros
des propositions de projets de loin et
bien hier nous en avons passé nous
allons passer une résolution qui est sûr
les associations et nous avons passé
surtout quelque chose de très important
qui était attendu par les territoires et
notamment par les intercommunalités
c'est une précision sur la loi qui
devait entrer qui rentrent en exécution
au 1er janvier 2018 sur la taxe j'aime
api qui existe déjà et dont la
compétence a été transférée aux pc y est
bien aujourd'hui on a réussi hier
à l'unanimité s'est passé dans
l'hémicycle de laisser le choix encore
aux intercommunalités pendant deux ans
de déléguer cette compétence ou soit aux
sociétés mixtes d'économistes ouverte
qui sont en place déjà et qui traite de
cette question là de manière à ne pas
aller dans l'erreur et redonner une
compétence un opci qui pour l'instant ne
s'en est pas forcément pris en charge
voilà c'est le genre de choses
effectivement qu'on amène après on a des
combats à l'intérieur de la majorité
qu'on gagne pas forcément on s'est
battus notamment sur la page n'a pas
gagné on s'est battu sur sur la csg
parce qu'on trouvait que le seuil était
trop bas et qu'il fallait mettre un
seuil qui était un seuil de la moyenne
des retraites perçues par nos retraités
on n'a pas gagné bon voila mais c'est
comme ça c'est la vie ma frustration
envers moi est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment d'être entendu en tant que
représentant modem au sein de cette
majorité républicains marche alors oui
oui on est entendu on a entendu parce
qu'il ya des choses qui se passent en
amont avant que ça arrive dans
l'hémicycle quand même heureusement on a
des relations assez fluide avec les
cabinets ministériels que ce soit
matignon ou des différents ministères
pour lesquels on travaille moi je suis
13 en relation très souvent avec le
cabinet nicolas hulot et je veux dire ça
se passe excessivement bien et ce qui
est important à noter ce dont on aurait
pu avoir peur c'est qu'ils ont besoin
énormément de remontées du terrain et
donc ma présence en circonscription est
importante parce que c'est grâce à ça on
peut des fois corrigé certaines petites
tendances sur certains textes car avant
même qu'ils arrivent à l'hémicycle
quelques questions tous nommés au lien à
l'actualité votre regard par rapport à
tout ça on va profiter de votre présence
vous n'êtes pas là uniquement pour
parler de cette fédération
yveline modem il ya eu le
de ce budget en large majorité à
première lecture à l'assemblée c'était
fin novembre ce budget recettes dépenses
est ce qu'il vous satisfait ce texte
avec un objectif revenir dans les clous
européens des 3% de déficit alors
revenir dans les clous européens des 3%
de déficit c'est une nécessité
on a atteint un taux d'endettement qui
est insupportable et si on veut envoyer
des signes de confiance vers les pays
étrangers et notamment vers nos
partenaires européens il faut qu'on
rentre dans les clous donc c'est vrai
que le budget était contraint parce que
quand même on a on a trouvé quelques
mauvaises surprises
en arrivant et notamment alors vous me
direz c'est toujours pareil hein la
dernière année d'un quinquennat on ouvre
le chéquier ont fait des chèques et
évidemment il n'y a pas d'argent pour
pour honorer ces chèques malgré tout on
a réussi dans un budget contraint 1
on a réussi l'exercice alors d'aucuns
diraient que effectivement on n'a pas
mis assez laoula bonjean pour ça on
l'entend mais le premier but de ce
budget c'était un art qu'il soit sincère
et c'est le cas et 2 surtout qu'on
contiennent le déficit en dessous des 3%
des 2,8 2,9 et du coup l'exercice a été
si ce n'était pas facile je tiens à
féliciter bruno le maire et gérald
darmanin parce que l'exercice cette
année était particulièrement difficile
il ya des mesures emblématiques sans
parler de la transformation de l'usf
peut-être plus sur la taxe d'habitation
qui sera exonérée pour 80% des ménages
ça va s'échelonner sur plusieurs années
c'est pas forcément très bien vécu par
les collectivités sur les ressources aux
journées parce que il ya eu une campagne
de désinformation sur la taxe
d'habitation qui a été énorme
alors bien jouer l'opposition à l'avant
dans son rôle je dois le reconnaître
d'habitation c'est la ressource
majar pour les collectivités en deux
points là dessus 1 elle est compensée à
l'euro l'euro parce que ce n'est pas
c'est pas une compensation justement
c'est un dégrèvement donc ça veut dire
que les maires toucheront à l'euro
l'euro ce qu'ils ne percevront pas des
administrés 2 quand j'entends les maires
dire qu'on a plus de levier fiscal
ce n'est pas vrai il a joué très claire
du coup ça va éclairer les administrés
c'est très bien ce n'est pas vrai on va
prendre un exemple simple vous avez une
taxe d'habitation à 10%
bon d'accord vous avez 80 % de notre
population qui est exonéré de cette taxe
d'habitation
le maire a besoin pour des raison
d'investissements sur sa ville
d'augmenter de passer la taxe à 12%
je vais être très clair il ya des gens
qui ont peut-être pas compris tout ce
qui n'était pas exonérer ils vont payer
12 % et ceux qui étaient exonérés vont
payer 2 % voilà donc à être compliqué
pour les merrains d'expliquer ça parce
que d'un côté on leur dit vous êtes
exonérés de la taxe d'habitation de
l'autre côté sister du levier il y aura
un petit pourcentage
enfin 2 % c'est quoi beaucoup mieux que
12ème tour dernier mot bruno myle yens
on évoquait tout à l'heure le la place
du modem au sein de la république en
marche et quelquefois vous prenez
position aussi sur des sujets où vous
n'avez pas forcément les bonnes grâces
des de la république en marche et sur un
point très précis c'est l'intégration de
la grande couronne dans le nouveau grand
paris c'est l' inverse de ce qui doit
être acté anormalement la fin de l'année
alors là vous vous avancez sur le fait
que celle inverse de ce qui doit être
acté le président macron à consulter
voilà c'est pas ce qui se dit en tout
cas vous votre position certes non mais
c'est pas une question d'avoir les
dernières infos ou pas je vous dis ça
mais je sais qu'il a reçu tous les
responsables politiques un importance
moi je fais simplement une remarque
concernant le la région métropole comme
je l'appelle ou la métropole régionale
appelez ça comme vous voulez pourquoi je
veux que ce soit sur le périmètre de
l'île de france d'abord un si on reste
sur le périmètre qui étaient inscrits
aujourd'hui on va encore ostracisé un
petit peu plus la grande couronne et ça
c'est insupportable déjà qu'on n'a pas
vraiment les moyens
on n'a pas les mêmes moyens que les
urbains en terme en terme
dessous de sonnants et trébuchants on va
encore être les parents pauvres de
l'histoire 2 il ya une compétition
internationale qui se joue au niveau des
métropoles qui est phénoménal en termes
d'attractivité pour les entreprises
étrangères et le travail qui a été fait
à la région notamment par jérôme
chartier donc là je loue son action de
définition des pôles d'attractivité
c'est à dire des pôles de compétitivité
et des pôles d'urbanisation ça va bien
au delà de la deûle à peu de la petite
couronne
donc on ne peut pas laisser tout un pan
de l'île de france comme ça marche et à
une économie différente de celle de la
deûle de la métropole dont déjà le
périmètre défini aujourd'hui est
contraint ils ne peuvent plus ils ne
peuvent plus faire d'expansion
économique
ils ne peuvent plus faire d'expansion
démographique donc ils vont arriver de
toute façon sur la grande couronne donc
allons-y et faisons j'en ai discuté avec
valérie pécresse d'ailleurs et faisons
de l'île de france qui a quand même
beaucoup de territoires vert et
agricoles faisons de l'île de france un
pôle d'attractivité de l'agriculture du
21e siècle avec des technologies
innovantes et à paul d'actrice
d'attractivité environnementale et
d'économie verte
voilà ça c'est dans les dents les dans
les tuyaux de valérie pécresse je ne
vois pas pourquoi on ne suivrait pas ça
merci ben miled est revenue pour 7,8
politique du mois de décembre on se
retrouve en janvier pour une nouvelle
émission avec de nouveaux est l'invité à
bientôt
[Musique]